what's an event it's a difficult
question not because we lack definitions
but because there are too many
definitions in my book I focus on event
in the sense of something extraordinary
takes place but with all this white span
of what we call an event I think an
elementary structure can be described in
formal terms within a certain field of
phenomena where things go on the normal
flow of things from time to time
something happens which as it were retro
actively changes the rules of what is
possible in the sense that something
happens it is generated by that
situation of course it causally produced
by the situation but in a way it changes
Ritter actively the whole situation it's
a miracle
in the sense of the event would have
been an effect which is stronger than
its own cause for example now come a
couple of examples that I hope we will
all like in literature
why is Casca Franz Kafka the one that we
all know and love and then of course he
has predecessors we can say that Casca
implicitly or explicitly relied on a
whole series of other artists like Edgar
Allan Poe Dostoevsky William Blake and
so on but it's not as simple as that
because when you try to isolate in those
earlier authors what makes them
predecessors of Kafka you can see that
dead dimension Casca before Kafka is
perceptible only once Tosca is already
here as Bohr has the Argentinian writer
as he put it in a wonderful concise way
truly
all authors writers have predecessors a
truly great writer in way create his own
past his own predecessors so that yes
there are people who influenced him but
you can see this influence all only once
he is here and now let me jump to a
totally different domains love love in
the good old-fashioned sense which is
today more and more rare love is an
encounter this is why in English and
also in some other language is not all
like French you use the term fall we
fall in love this is the eventual
dimension in what sense let's say you
live a happy life you are lucky you have
a job you meet regularly with friends
you are not in love you just make one
night strange maybe here and there you
meet every evening with friends you
drink you go to blah blah then all of a
sudden in a totally contingent way let's
say you stumble on the street somebody
help you to stand up it's a young girl
or boy blah blah and of course it's the
love of your life a totally contingent
encounter but the result can be that
your whole life changes nothing is the
same as they say you even spontaneously
perceive your entire past life as
leading towards this unique moment you
know the illusion of love is oh my god I
was waiting all my life for you this
something like this would have been the
love event and I think it's getting more
and more rare today many intelligent
cultural critics notice how we are
almost returning to pre romantic
pre-modern times when marriage or love
connections were a matter of relatives
counsellors and so on your uncle your
own they selected
you will marry and so on today it's
similar only instead of all those old
wise uncles and so on it's dating
agencies marriage agencies and John and
so on what we what they offer us is
precisely love without the fall without
falling in love without this totally
unpredictable traumatic encounter and
that's what I find very sad I think that
today we are simply more and more afraid
of this event
encounters you encounter something which
is totally contingent but the result of
it if you accept it as an event is that
your entire life changes it's a
different story this is why I think that
this avoiding falling in love is the
same phenomenon as a standard joke that
I use in my all my almost all my books
you know how we want to date the thing
without the bet aspect of it without the
price we have to pay for it we want I
don't know we want sugar without
calories show we have sweeteners we want
beer without alcohol we want and so on
and so on and I claim it's the same
thing in sexuality we want brief safe
sex sexual encounters without the fall
without this fatal attachment and I
think this is the most sad thing here's
the given what is slowly emerging as
maybe the predominant ideology today
what I Arana Cleary fir - as Western
Buddhism
life is just a playoff appearances don't
take it too seriously maintain a proper
distance don't get too attached to early
objects
it fits perfectly this superficial
consumerist attitude so again events are
rare an event is the traumatic
encounters which to put it in moral and
philosophical terms retro actively Cree
ate its own God